through a combination of diet and a
dialysis within weeks we will terminate
the cancer once and for all
nine essential amino acids eleven of
them so if we take away five or six of
those in a way it will only stop cancer
cell to death but not the normal cells
it killed all the cancer types that we
have tried so it seems we are hitting on
a universal feature weakness of all
kinds of cells what's up everyone we are
at Indy bio demo day November 6th 2018
in the herps theater in San Francisco we
are super excited this batch of
companies is just incredible the first
person we are going to be talking to is
Jian Li he is the founder of filter
scene which is depriving cancerous cells
of their nutrients this is very exciting
stuff thank you for coming onto the show
and talking to us yeah so
congratulations you already even closed
your 5 million dollar seed round which
is incredible congratulations so tell us
about you know tell us about you first
how did you even decide that you wanted
to do this I always so I the biologists
that I always focus on the chemists
chemical foundation of biology if I can
understand from the chemical perspective
I think I I think that is something
right so from there I'm Ivo cancer as a
fundamental chemical problem so we want
to fix it from a data level and so how
did you latch into so on the chemical
side of biology yes and then how did you
latch into cancer as the one that you
wanted an approach okay so I mean it is
very well known it's like almost 100
years out of discovery called a Warburg
effect we all know cancer cells the
order to grow rapidly they have to they
have to give up something
so I mean by so we know that about to me
it's like a kind of like a strange like
not many people are targeting on that
perspective with a real effective
solution so we start our company by just
taking that perspective and figure out
our unique solution hopefully we will
terminate the cancer once and for all
and this is drug free yeah so how do we
deprive the cancer cells of nutrients
okay so because the targets are
nutrients from the beginning we figured
we do not need a drug to take them away
there's already existing technic
technology there right so first the we
just want to cut off the nutrients so
basically we do another either then we
want to also overcome this internal
compensation so we need a technology
that helps to remove the last trace of
the target the nutrients that is
dialysis so with with our own tweak and
the dialysis part we will achieve
effective and a fast new Trinita
privation within wakes so our so the
treatment will last only a few weeks if
we are successfully got approved by the
FDA and that is so incredible it's just
a few weeks treatment what does what
does it look like when the cancer cell
is first being depleted of nutrients is
that through a process like fasting or
what how do we do it drug-free how do
you do a drug-free with no shape okay so
so we cannot achieve simply stop the
patients mm-hmm so starvation is a
straightforward idea but the run because
when you're stuck patients actually the
body will respond to some internal
signal whether it see whether it's a
from the cancer cells are from the other
part of the body but basically the body
will break it down itself to nurture for
those processes so that's why that's why
often you'll see the kinds of patients
they lose a significant part of their
body mass usually a good good part
not effects usually muscle
yeah so so the so our approach is
different because we only take away
those nutrients that are known I mean if
you take it away I mean I know to be
essential only for cancer cells and
which nutrients are we talking about so
there is a lot by the current early wave
focus on amino acids that is yeah that
is the effective enough in which do we
know which amino acids yes there's
affect yeah wait focused so amino acids
the 20 amino acids that make up all the
proteins in our body they are divided in
two groups one group is called the
essential amino acids so essential amino
acids are required to buy both but
cancer cells and normal cells so we do
not take them away yes but there's
another group called nine essential
amino acids 11 of them so if we take
away five or six of those in a way and
it will only stop cancer cell to death
but not the normal cells we have done
this experiment in imagery experiment
while we were at a Stanford so it does
not hurt the normal cells interesting
okay so about five or six non-essential
amino acids and do we do we deprive
certain foods that make those amino
acids or how do we stop those
non-essential amino acids from so
currently we are we are doing a formula
diet so basically the protein yeah
protein part of the other diet is a
mixture of the amino acids we want to
feed the patients not at the cancer so
that which means it does not contain all
20 amino acids but part of them
by cut off the supply of those we can
large and they take away this feeding
into the patient then what do we need is
is is is effective and the fast
technology which is dialysis the second
part okay so the first so the first part
is you have a formulation of a diet that
that stops those five or six is
non-essential amino acids then the
second part is the DA dialysis which
what does the dialysis do okay let's see
the first part if you feed the patients
with our formula diet
patients will survive but the target and
nutrients we want to take away the
target nutrients probably will will in
the bladder will drop down maybe let's
say 20% I make this up but that 20 20
percent is still able to nurture the
cancer cells although you I mean you
know restrictive like a manner but still
like a cancer cells can grow on that but
if we wait see if we drop down that
enable to below five percent and they
will kill cancer cells and dialysis does
exactly that apart by removing the last
of trace of that from the body quickly
and efficiently so how how does the dial
how do I get hooked into dialysis and
how would it take that last part out
okay
so die so common commonly dialogue
dialysis can be performed in two ways
we caught the hemodialysis and
peritoneal dialysis hemodialysis is you
you'll basically exchange the nutrient
composition between your dialysis fluid
and up a lot so that's a quick and
efficient way and there's also
peritoneal dialysis so you basically use
the body cavity in your tummy so that is
a natural dialysis membrane so if you
inject the dialysis fluid into the body
cavity that remembering will will do the
trick
so we exchange the nutrients across from
a new sign outside so both ways are
doable I mean for our therapy depending
on the convenience and the cost
consideration for the patients so we
were so so our dial is so fluid that
will be supplied to support both kinds
of dialysis practice and so then the
dialysis is what is in the dialysis that
makes it able to take the last part out
okay that's a little bit the country
intuitive okay so okay so that so so
first I should explain how the analysis
works so dialysis works is is working on
a membrane so that a membrane has a pore
size it does not allow the large
molecule to pass this room so basically
in dialysis you do not expect exchange
you do not expect the loss of Lexie
proteins ourselves from the patient's
it's only the small molecule stuff yes
usually we call them nutrients from
Earth from the body fluid yes yeah so
interesting so so then the body fluid is
running out through the dialysis and
then the dialysis machine is preventing
the small molecules from going back into
the body right it's it's it's it's
through exchange so basically say so
it's again chemistry we've got a ton of
gradient so say if you mix a dance sugar
solution with water glass of water right
the then the outcome will be less sweet
right yes
dialysis is so the reason is because the
sugar is moving from the more
concentrated apart-er to the last
concert in silences works that way so
what is not in our dialysis fluid is
going to be drawn out from the body
across the down the gradient say if we
have a huge friend X we want to take
away from the patient we just do not add
X in our fluid so indices that acts the
neutral axis will move down its chemical
concentration gradient to our fluid that
causes net
flow out yeah okay cool that's clear
yeah so then that's how you get the last
couple percentages out of the body
exactly and then that's only a couple
weeks that only takes a couple three
three or so weeks to do with all of this
from the form diet formula to the
dialysis and then the probably a revisit
to the later to check up and maybe a
couple weeks to make sure it's not back
yeah so usually so our current
estimations it takes probably just two
weeks to get through that level through
a combination of the diet and the
dialysis but then the rest time of the
treatment is designed to maintain that a
depletion level for a period of time so
the kinds of cells have a chance to die
this is brilliant
and then I want to know then what about
the you said it was at Stanford that you
were running these right first we
initial assets we could do that you made
us okay so basically we tested we take
away the nutrients from the media so
Union virtual assets you'll culture
cancer cells in a medium yes data medium
is actually in equivalent to to plot yes
yes so you interpreted like a nutrient
composition then we just formulated our
own medium so just drop out those
nutrients and test okay if cancer cells
can grow back so it's from there we know
what the nutrients are needed and it
it's not like a chop out of the
nutrients not only like a kill one or
two kinds of like I should adjust now it
killed all the kinds of types that we
have tried so it seems we are hitting on
a universal feature weakness of all
kinds of cells and this can work across
all cancers in all different organs or
tissues or any you think I would hope so
although I have only test data like a
six major types of a cancer and
including like a 18
subtypes Wow now have now we have more
yeah wow this is incredible - excellent
excellent work and that's why you know
that's why you're so well you know so
received on on the seed round just
completely filled up and now ready to go
move forward so what is the next step
for you with us with the seed round no
ok because we are drugged afraid we have
this unique opportunity to launch and at
least part of our therapy as a as a
product that does we do not need the FDA
approval so make it available to the
conservation as as soon as possible so
estimated we can launch something next
year in I must wow this is that you can
get the formulation diet out and then
you can get the diode to get them
plugged into the dialysis across where
they live and and wow just like that's
super fast it's awesome because they
have to do the FDA and getting far
approval is that as a whole long process
yeah red tape so the regular pass is
pretty clear for us now because the
dialysis is commonly like practice the
in clinic is already so there is no
issue over it's a safety actually there
is no scientific reason to believe our
product is not as safe I mean our
dialysis food is not a safe actually
it's a safer than the current dialysis
fluid fluid and then the only thing
would be then the formula we have to
figure out that make sure yeah formulas
yeah make it a safe so still nurturing
the normal cells apart to stop in the
cancer cell
yeah exactly so then do you end up
hiring who do you end up hiring in the
next nine months to make it happen yeah
we are expecting expanding hopefully
quickly yes so we need expertise to like
people to help us with the preclinical
studies basically animal studies we
needed somebody to in to develop the
food product for us make hater like a
tasty as tasty as possible yeah also we
need them like a manager to to make the
food and not only on lab scale but on an
industrial scale making it available to
as many patients as possible
yeah and then finally we need someone to
supervise our clinical trial trials
which we will probably start doing next
year yeah yeah Wow
I love it I love it I you have to all
the right pieces in it in it and it
sounds like the your the next steps that
you have planned are exactly what you
need I am very grateful thank you for
sitting Donald doesn't teaching us about
this hopefully they can live in a in a
deprived the nutrients that cancer cells
need it's a drug free solution it's so
incredible great work thank you Eric
thank you so much for sitting down with
us thank you thanks
[Music]